thank you in 2002 we launched Xbox Live
where anyone playing any type of game
can group up to make new friends and
compete with gamers around the globe
your desire to play more has led us to
invest continually an Xbox Live we're
bringing more live servers closer to
where gamers are resulting in a faster
more reliable network Xbox Live was
built by the passion of millions of fans
listening to your feedback is one of the
most important things we do it has
inspired us to deliver on Xbox one
backward compatibility to bring you the
new Xbox one experience and most
recently frost Network played Xbox Live
so more people can play together one one
of my favorite games rocket league
recently enabled this across all of the
networks that allow it your feedback
drives us every day and because of it
we're excited to bring new features to
Xbox one this summer like background
music so you can listen to your favorite
music while you play language region
independence letting you choose your
preferred language no matter where you
live and bringing the intelligence of
Cortana to Xbox one Xbox Live is
available on whatever device you use a
Windows PC and Xbox console an iOS or
Android device now I want to talk about
three of the most requested features
that will be coming this fall and
available for every game and every gamer
first Xbox Live has a great diversity of
gamers representing different playstyles
interests and genres the challenge is
finding people with shared interests and
having a place to talk about the games
we love today I am pleased to announce
clubs on Xbox Live
here you can create communities and meet
people you can always go back to that
love the same things you do
drift bans and Forza Motorsport
minecraft creators or division agents
right here in LA and everything in
between
next you told us it needs to be easier
to find the players you want to play
with right now so I'm excited to
announce looking for group on Xbox Live
it's like a wan ad for multiplayer and
it's the simplest way to find other
gamers with a shared goal in mind if
you're a division agent looking for two
experienced players to run the latest
incursion or a minecraft builder looking
for architects to build the world's
greatest temple you'll find them on Xbox
Live finally competitive gaming has
always been at the core of Xbox whether
you're a seasoned throw or a casual
gamer we want to unleash competitive
gaming for everyone we're excited to
announce arena on Xbox Live a new
tournament platform it's the easiest way
to discover register and compete all in
one place where you can compete solo or
with your friends in your favorite games
in addition to our Microsoft Studios
titles you'll be able to sign up for
tournaments from top publishers like
daybreak high-res wargaming and more but
you can't talk about competition without
mentioning EA Sports so today we're
excited to announce the EA will be
bringing some of their biggest games
like fifa to arena in the coming years
so starting this fall you'll have great
places to hang out with clubs you'll
find the people you want to play with
using looking for group and you'll
experience the best tournaments in arena
Xbox Live is the place to play thank you
and I'll see you online